aymeric montville bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france alors on le disait le rapporteur
a des nations unies sur la torture nils
miles exhortent le président américain a
gracié julian assange et il alerte la
vie du fondateur de wikileaks toujours
incarcéré est en danger qu'est ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui la santé de julian
assange et de ces conditions on sait
qu'il a des problèmes de sentiers qui
une maladie pulmonaire c'est pour ça que
le 26 novembre dernier il a refusé de se
présenter à l'audience à laquelle il
doit se présenter selon le droit
britannique tous les tous les 28 jours
parce que effectivement il risque gros
étant donné les l'épidémie de kovy de
foyer épidémique qui c'est qui s'est re
qui a qui a cours actuellement dans la
prison où il était incarcéré alors ce
n'est pas la première fois que le
rapporteur de l'onu tire la sonnette
d'alarmé en novembre 2019
nils mail avait demandé sa libération
immédiate
alors comment comprendre que les
britanniques aujourd'hui bien continue à
faire la sourde oreille
écoute c'est vrai que en ce moment avec
le webzine avec campus l'épidémie
malheureusement on leur parle de
beaucoup d'autres choses
pourtant effectivement c'est quelque
chose qui concerne leur liberté liberté
de n'importe quel journaliste à pouvoir
parce que c'est les états unis veulent
pouvoir appliquer à un droit
extraterritoriale il s'agit là de la
liberté de n'importe quel journaliste au
pouvoir faire son métier
d'autant plus qu'on sait maintenant que
toutes les accusations vous portez
contre julien lachance sur le fait qu'il
n'aurait pas protéger certaines
personnes mises en cause sans qu'il
aurait mis en danger la vie d'autrui en
publiant ces documents c'est
complètement faux puisque non seulement
on l'avait vu dans un dans un film qui
s'appelait risque en train de négocier
directement avec le département d'état
pour dire effectivement qu'il ya
peut-être des noms à retirer mais là on
a il ya un document qu'il ya quelques
jours et est paré où on voit une heure
de conversation avec
un avocat du département d'état on voit
que assange en fait c'est de trouver
toutes les solutions y compris là pour
pour éviter les désagréments à certaines
personnes me en plus à des publications
qui n'était pas de son fait puisqu'on
sait maintenant que c'est un concours
enfin c'est ce que ce que ce que ce
document après apprend ce sera un
concurrent qui s'appelait un ancien
numéro 2 de wikileaks appelle d'hommes
schatzberg et qui aurait lui sans aucune
précaution dévoiler ce des volets cela
et on fait ce qu'on peut
ce qu'on voit aussi effectivement c'est
que le rapporteur de l'onu a tenu à
préciser que julian assange n'était pas
un ennemi mais du peuple américain c'est
important de souligner là encore oui
tout à fait je pense que si on peut pas
dire autant justement des dirigeants
étasuniens et de la politique
impérialiste qui mène qu'il mène dans le
monde entier c'est c'est un peuple qui
en opprime un autre ne serait être libre
c'est la phrase de marx je crois que les
états unis en paie le prix
tout tout tout au tard par une animosité
dans le monde entier par rapport aux
libertés qui déclenche y compris contre
le droit international et le droit de
l'eau et nuit alors il y a quelques
jours
julian assange a fait l'objet de rumeurs
au sujet d'une grâce qu aurait décidé de
lui accorder donald trump ou encore
d'une hypothétique libération sous
caution pourquoi soudainement ces
rumeurs ont fait surface il est clair
que donald trump d'après ses avocats
jennifer robinson
robinson aurait proposé donc la grâce en
échange de quelque chose c'est le fait
que assange révèle la source du piratage
des courriels du comité national
démocrate en 2016 qui est une forme de
chantage et il faut savoir que bon
évidemment 7,7 grâce serait une bonne
chose pour assange pour la liberté
d'expression mais ce n'est pas
satisfaisant parce qu'une façon ce sont
les états unis qui sont fautifs
dans cette affaire le ce qui me semble
plus évidemment il faut saluer
l'initiative allemand qui est qui est
très bonne pour le mot comme ça qu il
faut savoir aussi que le parlement de
genève lui avaient voté carrément aller
à la quasi-unanimité l'obtention d'un
visa et militaires pour l'instant la
balle est dans le camp de la veille
france qui d'après le journal suisse le
temps
le
la défense représentée par le père john
shipton juge prématurée cette démarche
mais je pense qu'il serait temps de la
mettre en oeuvre c'est à dire deux mots
parce que l'art en ce moment le
parlement
je n'ai fait d'accord le conseil d'état
suisse à valider donc il serait temps
qu'on fasse cette demande de visa
humanitaire alors dans sa demande de
grâce deux rapporteurs de l'onu insiste
un julian assange chauffe pour avoir dit
la vérité à partir de révélations
obtenues par des sources le monde
médiatique s'en émeut très peu
finalement du sort d'assange comment
vous l'expliquez jeu propre c'est un peu
ce que v10 de noam chomsky c'est à dire
que il a révélé la façon dont
fonctionnent les puissants et
malheureusement le savez bien qu'en
france il ya nous sommes dédiés 9
milliardaire qui possède la plupart des
médias dominants donc ils sont quand
même du côté du pouvoir
d'une certaine manière ils n'osent pas
tellement ruer dans les brancards même
si là il faut reconnaître que c'est
l'entièreté du métier de journaliste qui
est qui mise en cause à travers la
personne d' assange
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que snowden et
est monté au créneau y compris pour dire
que la ces nouvelles révélations
je vous le dis sur cet enregistrement
qui a été publié le blanchissent est
complètement il va bien il a bien perçu
l'enjeu il était assez discret snowdon
ménage pas qui je crois qu'il a bien
compris ce qui était en train de se
passer
le monde médiatique assez discret
jusque-là mais aussi le monde politique
hormis certains députés allemands vous
vouliez vous étiez d'ailleurs le 25
novembre dernier l'écrasante majorité
des députés européens ont rejeté un
amendement faisant référence à l'affairé
assange
mais là encore pourquoi l'europe se
préoccupe si peu du sort de julian
assange
oui un contraste effectivement entre ces
députés européens principalement
sociaux-démocrates d'ailleurs qu'ils ont
enclenchée qu'ils ont laissée en rase
campagne
là on voit bien que ces mécanismes
européens qui sont d'ailleurs si peu
démocratique ne tendent pas la
transparence et à l'apprécier en disant
des citoyens sur leurs députés
parce que c'était vraiment une très
grande légèreté qu'ils ont fait cela
bon c'est intéressant tout net cette
initiative allemande parce que ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que là ça les gens ne
savent pas c'est peu on en parle assez
peu c'est que la fondation qui est à
l'origine de wikileaks une fondation
allemande qui s'appelle navarro hollande
w a eu depuis la rolande sens comme le
pays mais sans le à la fin et vous avez
aussi le chaos computer club et donc il
ya sorte certainement d on l'a vu avec
ce dogme scheidt berck c'est tellement
aussi ancien numéro deux luc x qui
revient maintenant dans l'actualité on
voit qu'il ya aussi il ya tout un volet
allemand de cette affaire et c'est
intéressant au moins pour pour
comprendre un petit peu aussi les
origines de wikileaks parce que c'est je
crois que ça
bien sûr qu'il faut le sauver en tant
qu'individu ou même au prix d'une grâce
présidentielle c'est c'est tout à fait
important mais je pense que ce don est
fidèle à junas naissance et je vous la
vérité sur toute cette affaire surtout
ce qui s'est passé depuis le début y
compris dans quelles conditions a été
créée wikileaks peut-être un dernier mot
concernant la position de la halle tram
sur le sujet est ce que une grasse est
envisageable dans les prochains jours
selon vous c'est un côté beaucoup de
gens qui j'allais dire il se trouve
qu'il ya 36 mhz de gauche que je trouve
un peu un peu étonnant parce que c'est
vrai qu'on peut arguer du fait que de 23
ans a été moins belliqueux que ses
prédécesseurs et beaucoup de gens très
anti impérialiste pense que ce sera
certains pensent que ce serait dû au
fait que vous dans la trappe pour aider
ideas hétérodoxes par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs par sur les interventions
à l'étranger
je crois surtout c'est dû au fait que la
paire isme américains étant est en
retrait et henry est en déclin et peut
plus se permettre n'importe quoi donc
subjectivement je passe je vais pas
forcément confiance à à 30 je crois que
ça sa politique effectivement moins un
peu moins gravissime que celle de ses
prédécesseurs était dû en fait une
politique conjoncturelle et je pense pas
qu'il faille attendre de lui un geste
particulier même si bon il faut
reconnaître que sarah palin par exemple
qui aussi fait partie un peu des faucons
dans le corps d'un camp républicain elle
même est revenu sur ses propres
déclarations honteuses à propos de la
santé a proposé 1
de passer l'épongé merci beaucoup
aymeric montville pour ces précisions
concernant la situation de julian
assange
je rappelle que vous êtes écrivain
éditeur